[Applause]
it was heralded as a golden era of
relations between the uk
and china president xi jinping honoured
with a state visit
but five years on that vision is losing
its shine
britain furious at what it sees as
china's assault on hong kong with a new
security law
this is a grave and deeply disturbing
step i have the
depressing but necessary duty to report
to the house
that the enactment of this legislation
imposed by the authorities
in beijing on the people of hong kong
constitutes a clear
and serious breach of the joint
declaration
it is a sad day for the people of hong
kong and one which can only undermine
international trust in the chinese
government's willingness to keep its
word
and live up to its promises
for our part mr speaker the prime
minister and the government
are crystal clear the united kingdom
will keep
its word we will live up to our
responsibilities to the people of hong
kong
that means offering nearly 3 million
eligible residents
and their families the option to leave
their city for a new life in the uk
a big gesture for a government brought
to power
in part on a pledge to shrink
immigration
but hong kong is a special case it was
handed back to china
exactly 23 years ago after more than one
and a half centuries of british rule
the ceremony founded on a pledge to
guarantee its freedoms for another 50
years
but the uk accuses china of violating
the one country two systems principle
what's actually happened is a complete
overturning of the whole concept of
one country two systems of a high degree
of autonomy from hong kong
uh the destruction of the basic law
which was
china's own constitution for hong kong
all that's been scrapped and it's been
replaced
by a sort of orwellian law it's an
extraordinary
uh all straight out of 1984.
worst fears realized for pro-democracy
protesters
they've railed for years against what
they see as creeping control from
beijing
not so says china framing its
legislation as justified to keep the
peace
the right to protest and demonstrate
the freedom of speech freedom
of assembly etc are fully protected
under
this national security law and the basic
law why
because this national security law is
only targeting four categories
of offenses that is terrorism uh
sedition uh secession and also collusion
with foreign powers or foreign interests
to achieve these above three categories
of offenses
i don't think the majority of the people
of hong kong want to be guilty of these
fro
offenses and i don't think the british
government seriously
wants to support these four offenses
neither side is backing down on hong
kong this territory
once again a flash between london and
beijing
debra haines sky news